The general good experience,
I told my dad,
I wrote my dad this letter recently,
this getting real deep,
our number three of the podcast.
We get real deep.
We're pro nuance.
I'm ascending to my dad,
but he won't listen to this book.
I wrote this letter that was like,
listen man,
because I,
I had seen recently like his developing relationship with my son and like it
shot it,
put this thought in my head that,
you know,
my relationship with my dad,
the kids caring for me.
The fact that he stayed with my mom and they developed this like place for me to
grow and nurture me and allow me to become a person in that environment.
Like there was a north star for me when I left that environment.
Like I always,
I never wondered what my path was going to be.
I always could look up and be like that bond that I developed,
my family,
their love for me is like the thing that I'm always,
you know,
I'm looking back too,
but also looking forward to.
Because that's what defines me and regardless of what I do,
I can always fall back on that,
that my dad loves me,
my mom loves me,
I love them,
and I grew up like with the strength of soul because I knew I don't have.
I have friends that came from the same place that I did.
Same town.
I didn't Marilyn that odd on heroin.
They live in the same little suburb suburbia community that I did.
They had parents that were the same age.
They went to the same high school,
they lived in the same environment.
They went down one way.
I went down another and I truly do feel that that me going down that way was the
way that my parents like built this structure around me.
That was always a route,
that bond and that love and the things that that's very,
very fortunate and I.
and that's what in that me being able to later on in life,
see how fortunate I was to have that drove me to not fail
for someone like me.
It's so interesting to know that there's still a considerable amount of
speculation.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
Well,
it's,
there's a lot of speculation,
but it is pretty off the wall and then other people who think mine are off the
wall,
who's to,
who's to say,
okay,
I'm um,
I don't know man.
Okay.
You know,
did decent things in the past,
but you should just trust this abuse now.
So I guess that's what people think.
I don't know,
but you see,
if it was just me,
I could understand that,
but I've got these posts and I have a colleague who's done things on this too
and it can't be that we're all a little off the rails.
I think.
No,
it can't be.
There's something out there and now with their hawking points,
there's something people can really go out and look for and if they don't see it
in,
there's something funny going on somewhere.
If they do see them,
there's something else going funny on which,
which they'll have to think of another explanation,
unless it's my explanation.
They'll have to think of a different view from the current conflation view,
which is in real trouble with these observations.
As far as I can see,
there is hate speech in the world isn't you know you don't want it on your
platform,
but you got to decide what is hate speech,
when is
it really hate speech and when is it just ignorance,
and sometimes the best way to combat bad speech is to let that speech play out
and let good speech overwhelm it with logic and reason and a better argument,
right?
That's really what freedom of speech is supposed to be all about that we work
all this out.
As soon as you start censoring voices and telling people that you're not going
to allow them to talk,
boy you,
you start,
you create this atmosphere where you can start to choose what you're going to
allow through and when you're not going to allow through and then you're gonna
start censoring things that are far more subtle.
You're going to start censoring things that you know they don't seem reasonable,
but you've decided that it's already okay to sensor,
so you've censored this person,
negative sensor.
The next worst thing,
you're going to go down the line until it's just people that disagree with you
and then you're like,
oh,
well my world is perfect now when in fact it's actually just a bunch of people
that are talking shit about you.
Would you use just don't happen to know about it.
The dove,
the Dove Company,
they're probably their most successful campaign of all time has been one where
they argued that beauty is a social construct.
You're all beautiful in your own way.
Now that again is a beautiful message,
right?
Because if,
if I am someone,
if I'm a woman who doesn't score well on the typical evolutionary cues,
then what do I want to hear?
I want to hear that there is no such thing as evolutionary cubes.
It's all socially constructed,
right?
If I have sagging breast,
if I have poor skin and so on,
if I have wrinkly skin,
I'd like to believe that there is no such thing as an universal beauty
standards,
and in that sense dove has been incredibly successful because by peddling false
hope,
they've actually been able to tap into women's insecurities and incense.
That's good marketing,
right?
The cover of Cosmopolitan magazine that was widely criticized because they had a
morbidly obese woman on who was a bikini plus size model.
Yeah.
And they were challenging beauty norms.
Like this is a person that's eating themselves to death.
You've got fucking assholes.
And so your lack of discipline and your desire to shame people who exercise and
is what you're doing to make them feel bad because you feel bad that you can't
put the fucking cook cookies and cupcakes down as a lead you to try to push this
ridiculous standard.
And one of the things my point of view was,
could you imagine if the cover of men's health had an enormous fat guy with his
gut hanging over his belt and,
and people were saying the new standards of attractiveness for men have been
changed by Mike who just drinks beer and eat cake and be like,
get the fuck Outta here.
That's never going to fly.
It's not going to fly with men,
but it does fly with women.
Right?
And
by the way,
the fat acceptance movement doesn't just argue that you know not being 500
pounds is unattractive because of the patriarchy.
They actually argue that the medical evidence suggesting that there is a link
between obesity
and downstream bad effects is all bullshit.
They not,
not just that they there,
they also point to one incredibly flawed study that has been wildly disproven
that says that there's some sort of vigor or vitality involved in being
overweight because they get sick less.
There's no,
no truth to that whatsoever.
They only,
they only analyze people who were healthy at the time.
Like it's,
it's,
you can go and Google the study and find out the criticism of that study,
but it's 100 percent horseshit folks.
Being fat is not good for you.
It's really bad for you when you're as big as that woman on the cover of
Cosmopolitan magazine.
She's literally morbidly obese.
She's fucking dying.
She's addicted to food in a horrible way.
And to promote that and pretend that somehow or another this is okay,
and we're gonna.
We're gonna show new standards of beauty.
You Go,
you giant gelatinous bag of meat and tissue.
No,
that's a dying person who is addicted to food.
She doesn't want to look like that.
Most of my friends,
we all got busted for drinking and driving.
The best one was a buddy of mine.
They read his was like,
you know,
approximately four in the morning.
We noticed a Maroon VW,
Fox blowing its horn,
trying to pass on the right.
We pulled the defendant over
after repeatedly asking the defendant to stay in the car.
He got out of the car,
threw his keys at my feet and repeatedly stated,
lock me up.
I'm fucked.
And this was funny was my buddy was a good look can guy.
And the judge was a,
was a woman and when the guy read that,
you know,
lock me up,
I'm fucked up.
And he wasn't the brightest guy and he just kind of,
when he went like,
Ugh,
he's like put his head down like that.
And he was,
you know,
little pound puppy fucking looking dude.
And she,
uh,
she,
she gave him like a lighter sentence and because he was good looking.
I think so,
yeah,
plays in because my ugly people are complaining so much
they won't take the time to develop a fucking personality.
Right.
Some jokes do it.
The rest of us have to do like I don't get mad at Brad Pitt,
you know,
and have it be fucking because he's fucking beautiful.
I'm a fucking bald redheaded mail.
I know where I am in the pecking order in some of these fucking people who
planning right now who are mad that beautiful people get treated differently.
I understand racially speaking,
but you're not going to do the beautiful thing.
And then that's another thing they tried to say.
Well Society tries to,
you know,
they're the ones that fucking like,
like I love when like there's a supermodel,
like the,
this is like an impossible standard of beauty to try and live up to.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's why she's on the cover of a magazine.
She's that level.
Beautiful.
And you're going to try and sit there and tell me that that was learned.